so
our mandate here is we make video
content for the digital space
so that's what we do why we decided to
use vinylmation specifically
is we liked the fact that there were
these characters
and they were really cute and cool and
had a lot of potential to them
but they didn't have a narrative to them
already they didn't have a backstory
there was no vinylmation movie or tv
show or anything
so we were able to take those characters
and shape them into a story and that was
why vinylmation was really attractive to
us
and then it lends itself perfectly to
this stop-motion style
so the first three episodes release at
d23
and go live that sunday and then
following that it'll be one episode
every saturday
for the remaining nine episodes so
that'll take us to about the middle
of october hey guys look what just came
oh
the guys have been shooting the entire
time so we have behind the scenes photos
we have behind the scenes videos
we have concept art we have all this
stuff that will be
used on the tumblr and on facebook
to really keep buzz alive for the series
as we're ramping into it and
throughout and then after as well
you